m
16 membres de la secte tutor du temple
solaire dont trois enfants retrouvés
morts en partie brûlé dans le massif du
vercors nouveau suicide collectif ou
meurtre dissimuler des armes ont été
retrouvées sur place
sarajevo l'armée française est chargé de
surveiller ce premier noël de paix après
quatre années de guerre yasser arafat à
bethléem à la veille de noël président
de l'autorité palestinienne prend
possession de la ville après le retrait
d'israël
madame monsieur bonsoir 20h à l'heure
qu'il est les gendarmes ont retrouvé 16
corps dont trois enfants des membres de
la secte du temple solaire qui se serait
immolée par le feu dans une clairière du
massif du vercors plusieurs centaines de
gendarmes avaient été mobilisés ce matin
pour ratisser la région
ces femmes ces hommes dont l'identité
est encore inconnue ont donc été
retrouvé en partie brûlé mais il ne
s'agit pas forcément d'un suicide
collectif dans la mesure où des armes
auraient été découvertes sur place
valérie astruc benoît gallerey reportage
au bord de cette clairière caché par
quelques arbres les restes des seize
corps c'est ce corps dont ceux de trois
enfants retrouvés à proximité d'une
piste forestière
personne n'approche hormis les
enquêteurs un périmètre de sécurité a
été installé c'est un hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie qui a découvert les cadavres
ce matin à 8 heures il était situé à un
kilomètre de la route qui mène au col du
mont noir des corps n'ont pas encore été
touchées il se trouve toujours dans la
position que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire en forme de soleil en forme
pour nous
et
d'accord on t on celui de combustion
assez importante à l'aide
vraisemblablement de produits
inflammables des armes de poing et
d'autre d'une puissance plus importante
ont été retrouvés juste à côté des corps
sur le parking non loin de là les quatre
voitures des personnes recherchées par
la police genevoise
trois centimes matricule et en suisse
une en france ce matin
les démineurs sont intervenus puis les
gendarmes ont pris la succession pour
une première fouille ses véhicule avait
été aperçu dès samedi à plusieurs
reprises par les chasseurs et puis je
suis passé je pense à chebba simple
erreur mais j'aimais ses cultures je dis
pas de neige mais après j'ai dit mais
c'est les promeneurs c'est tout le drame
s'est produit dans un lieu reculé le
hameau le plus proche est à 5 km et
c'est là qu'un barrage a été installé
pour interdire l'accès au col aucun des
trois cents habitants n'a donc pu
prendre la route aujourd'hui seul le
maire du village s'est rendu sur les
lieux du drame
sans ce que le pacte aurions un sou
thomas
ici il y en a quatre heures plus tôt 16
ballons géants forme de soleil est à
l'arrière les pieds avant que cette
personne carbonisé de sa noire
c'est un taux de 6,1
ce soir la police scientifique est
arrivé sur place toute la nuit l'enquète
va donc continuer quant aux quatre
voitures des victimes elles viennent
d'être embarqué par les gendarmes pour
des vérifications plus complète
je vous disais on ignore pour l'instant
l'identité des victimes et notamment si
le fils et la femme de l'ancien champion
de ski jean vuarnet figurent parmi ses
victimes ce qui s'est produit dans le
massif du vercors ressemble d'une
certaine façon à ce qui s'était passé au
mois d'octobre 1994 dans un chalet
suisse et dans une villa du canada 53
membres de la secte s'était immolé par
le feu en compagnie de leur gourou luc
jours et on peut se demander pourquoi
donc
entre temps la police et la justice
suisse qui était chargé de l'enquète
n'ont pas mis un terme aux activités de
cette secte eric lemasson et rick george
le chef de la police de genève
accompagné de daniel dumartheray l'un
des juges d'instruction de la première
enquête sur le temple solaire sont venus
le dire clairement à la presse non il
n'y avait pas selon eux de moyen légal
d'empêcher un nouveau drame car en
suisse comme en france chacun le droit
d'exercer la religion de son choix qui
nous a surpris est vraiment fortement
surpris c'est que tout le monde était
persuadé sur le plan humain que la
première enquête entre guillemets avait
ouvert les yeux de certaines personnes
et comme aucune information en effet
nous étaient parvenues sur entriez mais
ce que certains qualifient de noyaux
durs ou bien sur l'organisation d'un
voyage à fortiori nous avions pas de
raison
de s'intéresser au phénomène la police
savait pourtant que les adeptes
survivants du temple solaire continuer à
se réunir et certains entendu comme
témoin avait expliqué qu'il regrettait
de ne pas faire partie du premier voyage
dans cette librairie ésotérique du
centre-ville le libraire avait recueilli
quelques confidences
ils ont qui continuent à ceux à se
réunir et il est même possible qu'ils
avaient un médium qui essaient d'entrer
en contact avec leur frère qui se
trouvait je crois que sur une autre dans
une autre galaxie sais pas si ses sirius
qui ne sait pas exactement quelle était
en avait entendu parler
j'ai entendu parler lui les
perquisitions effectuées au domicile des
16 personnes disparues ont permis de
trouver des lettres testament est
d'ailleurs l'entourage de patrick du
harnais et de sa compagne qui figurent
au nombre des disparus témoigne de
propos inquiétants entendu ces dernières
semaines ils avaient l'air de bien que
que l'on massacre de savants et chéri
était quelque chose de tout à fait
normal parce qu'il avait l'air de dire
que c'était ce sens était d appeler que
actuellement ce qu'on vivait sur cette
terre en approchait de l'apocalypse
personne ne peut ce soir affirmé qu'elle
était le degré d'organisation des
survivants du temple solaire
y avait-il un nouveau gourou existe-t-il
d'autres membres éparpillés en suisse ou
ailleurs
peut-être tout simplement ses adeptes se
sentait-il perdu et orphelins en direct
nos envoyés spéciaux venoix gadret dans
le vercors et eric lemasson agenais
benoît gadret d'abord ce soir les
gendarmes n'ont toujours pas dégagé les
corps de la clairière on les a retrouvés
ils vont travailler toute la nuit
alors effective effectivement daniel les
corps des sept victimes sont toujours
sur place
faut dire que les gendarmes au pair avec
une méthodologie extrêmement précises
dans cette enquête j'ai pu approcher
tout à l'heure le lieu du drame
un périmètre de sécurité a été établi et
cet après midi les hommes de
l'identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale ont procédé
pendant plusieurs heures à des examens à
des relevés autour des corps et c'est
seulement depuis quelques minutes que
deux médecins
jst examine de plus près les cadavres
avant le transport des corps à grenoble
probablement cette nuit ou demain matin
benoît on a parlé de ce maître griffiths
2 est ce que l'on peut parler également
peut-être aussi de meurtres dissimulés
dans la mesure où on aurait retrouvé des
armes sur place alors on sait que au
moment de la mort où quelques minutes
avant la mort les membres de la secte
était assis en position assise en arc de
cercle
il est possible que ces personnes est
été exécuté ou se soit suicidé par balle
dans la mesure où des armes de poing ont
été retrouvées à proximité des étuis
d'armes plus importante nous a dit le
procureur ont également été découverts à
proximité
et puis un liquide inflammable
probablement de l'essence a été répandu
sur les corps
le feu a été ensuite allumé on connaît
la suite alors l enquête devra
déterminer dans quel ordre ces décès
sont intervenus
et si une personne en particulier est à
l'origine de cette mise en scène
dernière chose très rapidement au benoît
pourquoi dans cette région du vercors
ah bah ça c'est un grand mystère daniel
tous les gens de ce magnifique que cette
magnifique région du vercors que nous
avons interrogé le comprennent pas ce
qui s'est passé ils n'ont jamais rien de
remarquer particulier le seul élément
troublant ce sont les noms des lieux
dits qui se trouve à proximité je
voulais site
le puy du diable ou le trou de l'enfer
cela concorde évidemment avec ce rituel
macabre mais ce n'est peut-être qu'un
hasard
merci eric lemasson maintenant à genève
alors éric conte et on lisait dans votre
sujet quelque peu étonné quand même
d'apprendre que finalement entre la
sphère de l'année dernière cette
terrible affaire et cette année et bien
il ne s'est rien passé on n'a pas
empêché cette secte de fonctionner alors
l'une des caractéristiques importantes
de l'hôtesse l'ordre du temple solaire
c'était le secret c'est vrai que c'était
une secte très hiérarchisée très bien
organisée mais très secrète savait
d'ailleurs considérablement gêné l'anc
est alors on peut imaginer soi que la
hiérarchie s'est reconstitué depuis le
drame
ou plus probablement que certains
adeptes survivants ont décidé d'aller
rejoindre leur gourou
jours et dix membres au des gourous qui
seul euro n'était pas mort d'ailleurs
puisque pour eux la mort n'existe pas
c'est simplement un passage vers un état
différent dans une autre galaxie sirius
est le moment propice c'est par exemple
les solstices et c'était il ya deux
jours le solstice d'hiver dernière chose
eric que l' enquête sur le premier
suicide collectif des de l'année de 94
n'était toujours pas terminé selon la
justice suisse
alors l'enquète n'était pas tout à fait
terminée cependant le juge peeler à
fribourg qui dirigeait cette enquête
avait achevé à achever la rédaction de
son mémoire d'instruction au mois de
septembre et ils s'apprêtent à la rendre
publique en janvier cette enquête a été
très longue c'est vrai son rapport fait
plusieurs centaines de pages pourquoi et
bien parce qu'on avait évoqué à l'époque
diverses hypothèses et notamment des
trafics d'armes des trafics de drogue du
blanchiment d'argent sale qui se
cacherait derrière ce excepte donc
toutes ces hypothèses ont été vérifiés
en australie au canada en france ensuite
en suisse et cela a pris beaucoup de
temps évidemment et il semble d'ailleurs
qu'on n'ait pas trouvé grand chose qui
se cacherait derrière sceqe secte mais
plutôt bel et bien un suicide collectif
ou alors des meurtres pour les gens qui
désirait rester sur notre terre merci
eric merci benoît parmi continuons notre
enquête parmi les 16 victimes possibles
deux policiers la famille de l'un
d'entre eux notamment domicilié dans le
vaucluse dans la commune de sarrians là
même où est établi un médecin homéopathe
docteur le gall qui fut en son temps en
relation avec le gourou de la secte luc
jouret enquête dans la région yannick
aroussi jean-françois giorgetti les
volets sont clos
il n'y a plus personne à l'ermitage le
docteur le gall et sa famille sont
partis ce matin en vacances en prenant
le soin de laisser leur adresse aux
gendarmes
car le docteur le gall est le dernier à
avoir vu jean-pierre la revanche est
l'un des deux policiers disparus qui
habitait également à l'ermitage la
revanche est venu le 15 décembre
chercher sa femme et ses deux enfants
c'est du moins ce qu'a déclaré le
docteur le gall aux gendarmes venus
l'interroger
christian mary de galets ce médecin
proche de l'udc jour et le gourou de
l'ordre du temple solaire
il partageait avec lui le cabinet
médical de l'ermitage est hébergé des
membres de la secte dans ces bungalows à
l'arrière de la maison
après plusieurs perquisitions et une
garde à vue en 94
le docteur le gall a toujours affirmé
qu'il n'appartenait pas à la secte on ne
m'a parlé de moi comme fournisseur de du
jour est point de vue financier or il
n'en est rien je peux prouver et je leur
ai prouvé par a + dec que nous avions
que des relations qui était humaine et
médicale
une nouvelle fois la sphère de l'ordre
du temple solaire a des ramifications
dans le vaucluse où la secte possède
plusieurs villes une nouvelle fois le
docteur le gall était en contact avec
les disparus patrick huard n'est par
exemple venait régulièrement séjourné à
l'ermitage invité de notre journal
madame tavernier madame tavernier
bonsoir vous êtes présidente de
l'association de défense de la famille
et de l'individu vous luttez contre les
sectes
on vient de voir un certain nombre de
reportages de résultats de nos enquêtes
est ce que toutes les sectes qui existe
ce soit en suisse en france ou ailleurs
en tout cette finalité aussi dangereuse
que serait la mort finalement pro plus
ou moins programmé
non heureusement non non il y à quelques
secte apocalyptique mais toutes les
sectes ne sont pas un peu khalip tic
heureusement et ont finalement jamais
guéri c'est ce qu'on peut se demander
d'avoir appartenu à une secte les
gourous sont morts dans la secte du
temple solaire di mambro luc jouret et
les membres continuent d'exécuter leurs
ordres sur terre vous savez les gens qui
sont dans les sectes s'investissent
complètement et en plus ils ont rompu
avec l'environnement la famille la
société
donc ils ne vivent que par la secte et
que pour l'affect donc cela qui restait
était sans doute un peu nostalgique et
puis le monde extérieur est tellement
dangereux qu'il fallait retrouver leurs
frères là-haut et leurs maîtres
donc ça ne m'étonne pas tellement nous
allons nous retrouver dans un instant
mais d'abord donc cette secte du temple
solaire dont pour l'heure 69 membres
sont morts à l'occasion des deux
suicides collectifs 94 et puis
aujourd'hui volontaire ou involontaire
il avait souvent été recrutés à partir
des années 70 dans les milieux
universitaires et parmi la bonne société
en france et en suisse notamment anne
consigny
en octobre 94 quelques jours après les
suicides collectifs de cherry et salvan
les policiers suisses détruisent et
brûlent les objets du culte du temple
solaire 53 personnes sont mortes de les
avoir adoré
on croit alors en avoir fini avec 7,7
pourtant l'esprit les mouches les
enseignements la voix peut être de luc
jouret le fondateur du temple solaire
ont poursuivi les survivants une voix ce
qui parle d'apocalypse
c'est au cours de cette apocalypse que
l'être humain a la faculté peut-être
pour la première fois de son histoire de
révéler ce qu'on appelle la conscience
juste
tout commence par un incendie
d'apparence banale dans cette ferme de
shérif en suisse le 5 octobre 94 mais
une fois les flammes éteintes les
pompiers découvrent dans une chapelle du
sous sol
les corps brûlés de 23 adeptes la
plupart d'entre eux ont été tués par
balles presque simultanément dans ces
chalets du valais toujours en suisse 25
corps sont découverts calcinés ici pas
de trace de balle mais du poison
même scénario au canada où la secte et
est implantée cinq cadavres sont
extraits des décombres d'une maison
appartenant à luc jouret et joseph di
mambro l'autre mètres de la scène on
pense alors que les chefs de l'ordre du
temple solaire ont monté de toutes
pièces suicide collectif pour
s'approprier les richesses du mouvement
mais très vite les travaux
d'identification réalisé à la morgue de
lausanne établissent que j'aurais et di
mambro sont au nombre des victimes
à l'époque le juge suisse andré pilaire
ouvre une enquête
il dira justement d'en recevoir le
rapport final qui ne permettra de dire
si ce massacre a été orchestré le drame
de saint pierre en chair elle n'apporte
pas plus de réponse mais il alourdit
terriblement le bilan 21 vernier le plus
difficile c'est d'agir contre ces sectes
parce que finalement elle se présente
souvent comme de banals d'associations
de la loi de 1901 et on ne peut pas
lutter contre un oui justement elle se
massent elles se cachent souvent
derrière le masque religieux donc on
dire vas pas lutter contre la liberté
religieuse que j'ai entendu dire tout à
l'heure mais c'est ça qui nous choque
beaucoup nous associations c'est tout
simplement un masque ça leur permet
d'avoir des agissements qui sont tout à
fait
regrettable en revanche on pourrait
peut-être faire quelque chose lorsque
des enfants sont impliqués
voilà alors justement tout à l'heure on
parlait beaucoup de suicides collectifs
je pense qu'il y avait trois enfants ils
ne se sont pas suicidés donc là je pense
qu'il faut vraiment rectifier un député
communiste aujourd'hui madame monsieur
brard qui fait partie qui est même vice
président de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire en france sur les sectes
affirme que celles ci ont infiltré les
hautes autorités de la magistrature de
l'assemblée war de l'état est ce que
vous pensez que danger là vraiment je
pense qu'il ya un danger c'est pas
simplement sets secs je pense que les
sectes un filtre pas mal toutes nos
instances non gouvernementales mais
aussi qu'est ce qu'elle cherche à faire
elles veulent prendre la planète
donc elle met des pions dans tous les
rouages de la société et ça c'est très
grave effectivement il faut se méfier
les sectes c'est un phénomène de société
et je crois j'espère que ce qui vient
d'arriver va nous permettre de réagir et
de prendre les choses sérieusement
dernière chose madame
on dit que là on pensait que la secte
avaient avaient disparu à l'occasion du
premier suicide collectif de 94 on s'est
aperçu de la que non il se pourrait
qu'elle existe encore vous pensez vous
qu'elle existe encore on savait qu'il y
avait encore des adeptes puisqu'il se
rencontraient ça nous le savions et tout
le monde le savait je pense qu'un encore
qui sont à l'extérieur et il faudra
encore se méfier tout à fait merci
madame
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire ce soir
sur cette tragique affaire autres titres
de l'actualité maintenant derniers
bastions de la grève des transports en
commun marseille aucun accord n'est
intervenu aujourd'hui entre la
municipalité et les grévistes du métro
et les autobus ont en revanche en ile de
france le trafic étant redevenues
parfaitement normal en cette fin de
semaine cette journée a marqué la fin de
la gratuité
les guichets de la ratp ont réouvert
laurent bailly didier rancoeur après
trois semaines de grève et une semaine
de gratuité royalement concédé par la
ratp
il faut donc de nouveau payé pour
prendre rer bus et métro en ile de
france
évidemment ça fait grincer quelques
dents dix étapes entre pour la mon
boulot mais c'est pas 4 heures du matin
et maintenant ils sont payés alors que
moi je comptais pas puisque fin janvier
il aurait pu emmener c'est gratuit
comment descendre en décembre un ticket
en tout cas quand je vois pas un
contrôleur passage je montrerai pas
menti con petite consolation tout de
même pour les utilisateurs de carte
orange qui ont renoué aujourd'hui avec
les files d'attentes
je récupère se défend je veux bien
échanger tout en janvier il sera là tout
de suite vous pouvez vous en servir
maintenant jusqu'à la fin du mois de
janvier
d'accord une semaine de gratuité cela
convient incertain même si les
rouspéteur bien sûr sont les plus
nombreux
et bientôt la ratp n'a pas fait cette
fleur à ces voyageuses
et tout indique aujourd'hui dans le
métro parisien que la situation est
redevenue normale tout à fait normal
l'actualité internationale sarajevo
s'apprête à fêter son premier noël de
paix après quatre années de guerre c'est
l'armée française à laquelle le ministre
de la défense monsieur millon a rendu
visite aujourd'hui qui est chargé en
quelque sorte du maintien de l'ordre et
de la paix dans la capitale bosniaque et
dans ses environs les plus proches
dorothée olliéric jean-françois hoffman
reportage ils partent pour une mission
de reconnaissance sur la ligne de front
eux ce sont les légionnaires du 2ème
régiment étranger de parachutistes
on est loin du concept de maintien de la
paix des casques bleus désormais avec le
nouveau mandat de le temps les hommes
sont parfaitement armés et prêts à faire
feu au moindre incident il ya des
soldats de la guerre les soldats de la
paix en la vie à des soldats soldats il
en suit une mission ils l'appliquent
et ils ont des nouvelles règles de
comportement et de numérique
d'engagement et donc c'est ce que ça
donne c'est quoi ces règles balearic
d'engagement c1 c'est toujours de
l'autodéfense mais c'est de
l'autodéfense qui élargit et surtout sur
le mois sur le terrain on a les moyens
de riposter en conséquence le parcours
est encore miné les légionnaires
marchent en file indienne pour rejoindre
les tranchées en haut de la colline à
20km de sarajevo
ici c'est un poste serait revue à une
centaine de mètres seulement ce truc des
positions croate encore terrés il y a
quelques jours les serbes sortent des
tranchées et vont même voir les croates
une bonne entente que le veulent tout de
même pas montré les limites
la garde est jamais vraiment fini s'il
le faut chacun regagnera sa tranchée
côté croate les relèves se poursuivre
aussi nuitées jours sur la ligne de
front
même si le dispositif est allégé et les
hommes passablement demi
on s'est tellement tiré dessus ici et
c'est fini on doit arriver à vivre
ensemble
mais ce qui est dur c'est qu'il nous
faudra oublier beaucoup beaucoup
d'erreurs malgré quelques incidents les
brigades de lits forts sont bien décidés
à faire respecter la paix aujourd'hui
ils font la tournée des positions mais
demain si les belligérants refuse de se
retirer
c'est avec les chars qu'ils viendront
parler de paix la pologne a changé de
président aujourd'hui le néo communistes
alexander bakiev qui a prêté
officiellement serment devant le
parlement son prédécesseur lech walesa
avait décidé de bouder la cérémonie
l'accusant de tricherie pour avoir menti
notamment sur son passé et la valeur de
ses diplômes monsieur valises à lui
n'est pas quitte pour autant puisque le
fisc lui réclame 5 millions de francs
pour une affaire de droits d'auteur qui
n'auraient pas déclaré monsieur
classifie assuré qu'il entretiendrait de
bons rapports avec l'église et qui
demanderait de l'entrée de la pologne
dans la communauté européenne
en bref encore 300 peut être 400 morts
dans une école du nord de l'inde ces
deux terrible bilan d'un incendie qui
s'est déclaré dans un lycée à l'occasion
de la fête annuelle des élèves et puis
nouvel assassinat en algérie un
réalisateur de la télévision algérienne
a été retrouvé criblé de balles
aujourd'hui dans la banlieue d'alger
enfin l'état de santé du premier
ministre grec monsieur papandréou s'est
encore aggravée ces dernières 24 heures
il ne survit plus que grâce à une
assistance respiratoire artificiel un
mois après son hospitalisation à athènes
passait sous administration
palestinienne depuis 48 heures à peine
bethléem la ville de la nativité du
christ a reçu à cette occasion la visite
du président yasser arafat accueilli par
une foule de plusieurs milliers de
personnes reportage véronique talent
bethleem aux couleurs palestiniennes
même l'église de la nativité ne pouvait
aujourd'hui
échappée et c'est à l'unisson que les
cloches de la ville ont accueilli yasser
arafat disent peut-être quinze mille
personnes
une foule compacte se pressait sur la
place centrale de bethléem quarante huit
heures à peine après le retrait l'armée
israélienne yasser arafat a tenu à venir
en personne proclamer bethléem ville
libérée l'île de la paix dans son
discours très applaudi le président de
l'autorité palestinienne a réaffirmé son
engagement envers le processus de paix
et le nécessaire dialogue entre
palestiniens et israéliens entre
chrétiens musulmans et juifs mais c'est
aussi son attachement à voir jérusalem
capitale du futur état palestinien qui
l'avons transmis aujourd'hui nous prions
avec les aime bientôt nous irons sein
c'est pile et à la mosquée d'al aqsa à
jérusalem at il déclaré une petite
phrase est aussitôt des centaines de
mains tendues et le v de la victoire
après 28 années de fondation cette année
d historique
les palestiniens sont heureux et fiers
il a parlé de l'unité entre chrétiens et
musulmans à la veille de noël et phase
est important historique symbolique
aussi la présence de mains de yasser
arafat le président de l'autorité
palestinienne devrait être assisté à la
veillée de noël ici à bethléem
l'actualité nous accorde rarement
malheureusement le privilège de pouvoir
raconter de belles histoires aux enfants
noël fait exception voici donc
l'histoire vraie d'un collégien et de
son petit hamster passager clandestin
des autobus londoniens londres
bernard lebrun oyez oyez les enfants le
père noël vous raconte une histoire une
histoire authentique une histoire
britannique
celle d'un petit hamster qui s'ennuyait
ferme à la maison loin de son maître un
jeune écolier pensionnaires sweep
le petit rongeur ne voulais pas attendre
les vacances de noël pour retrouver
wayne son propriétaire des coûts tant
que son coeur est à 11 ans on a le coeur
gros où elle décida d'emmener sweep avec
lui au collège mal lui en prit car sweep
le hamster n'était pas autorisé à
prendre le bus
forbidden interdite comment faire
solution en parler au père noël afin
qu'ils persuadent le patron chauffeur de
bus d'accepter hamster le chauffeur peut
prendre la décision à sa discrétion de
refuser des passagers des biens ou des
animaux dans ce cas précis il a pris la
mauvaise décision
la bonne décision la voici touché par la
grâce et l'esprit de noël
le tour de magie s'est accomplie sweep a
reçu sa carte de bus avaient photo
d'identité
s'il vous plaît et c'est ainsi que
depuis lors en angleterre roulant bus
chaque semaine le pensionnaire et le
gangster merci père noël
l'amérique qui nous envoie si souvent
les reflets d'un pays violent notamment
dans sa jeunesse observe également une
trêve de noël les jeunes que vous allez
découvrir blanc noir forment la chorale
de la grande cathédrale de washington
villiger en sortant de l'école nous
avons rencontré des enfants en apparence
comme les autres venant de tous les
milieux
avec un besoin de bouger peut être
encore plus grand car contrairement aux
autres petits américains
le foot la télé pour eux c'est limité si
je ne faisais rien je regarderai juste
la télé et il se serait pas bon pour
nous avec le programme de la chorale et
les devoirs qu'il a à faire à la maison
n'a plus tôt
chaque instant de répit est consacré à
la détente même si les couloirs de la
cathédrale ne sont pas tout à fait pour
ça là haut on perds mes yeux vous allez
découvrir vous verrez quand il chantait
qu'il travaille que ce sont des enfants
sacrément travail elle
ils sont vingt tous au collège
saint-alban une très bonne école être à
la chorale c'est pour les parents 25% de
remise ça aide
eux doivent allier obligatoirement chant
et travail de classe il reste quand même
des enfants avec leurs joies et leurs
malheurs les répétitions c'est en
général 18 heures par semaine avec noël
c'est plutôt 22
en ce moment c'est un vrai métier on
reste tard très tard mais on aime toutes
les musiques
tu préfères haendel ou l'arabe l'europe
ils ne se prennent pas au sérieux
il aurait même tendance à se moquer des
grands
l'angoissent n'a pas pris même pour
celui qui arrive souvent en retard thual
plaques
non pas vraiment il a jasé on a beaucoup
répété à la chorale et je pense que je
suis prêt ici ils sont chez eux un
terrain de jeu interdits
ils ont pris au mot celui qui a demandé
qu'on laisse venir à lui les petites
non
bové noël c'est encore un coup de minuit
voilà dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet 20h45 le bêtisier du
samedi arthur reçoit michel leeb et
christophe lambert journal de la nuit 01
45 florence dauchez quant à nous on se
retrouve demain à 13 heures et à 20
heures je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée sur notre chaîne à l'eau